[拍手]
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
今日はあります
今日は僕がの東北の支援だったりとか
学校の間瀬木も仕事の中で見つけた
頃の成長であったりとか心の器についてのお話をしてみたいと
僕学生時代に熱中していたものが2つあります
器合気道
もう一つは不
その不登校のキャンパーですねキャンプなんで転倒貼ったりとかカレー作ったりとかね
小原で駆け回ったりとかもうありとあらゆるアクティビティを子供たちと一緒にやり
ました
じゃあ楽しかったんですよね
それがですね僕のすごいやりがいだっ
であるとき
保護者の方と一緒に子供見てて保護さん言うわけですよ
いい顔ね見たことが入っ
ウソの話で僕だなぁもやっぱ良かったなって思ってるんですけど
放射はポロって言うんですよ
があると元に戻っちゃうんですねっていう
クリしてえっ
楽しくて新しくていい経験してるのに本当に盛っちゃってどういうことって言っ
その
もうは僕がプロのカウンセラーとして働き始めてか持ったところ中になりました
そしてこの緑の東北元気キャンプというものに言われました
このキャンプはもともとは不登校の子の支援の
そのキャンプは
女子同級シフトこの保育教師があるんですけどそこの在籍22名の子がキャンプご飯と
して
22学校に復帰しちゃうっていうものだったんですよね
そのプログラムを温度はん
福島県でいる
心臓もうした子どもたちのケアのためにドラマキャンプとしてやってみようというのが
このキャンプでした
どやってたキャンプと取っ違うんだろうなぁとすごい不思議に思ってこのキャンプ参加
しました
皆さんちょっとあの考えてみてください
このキャンプでは
に上るというねあっ
こんな感じでですねあの子供にハーネスをつけて10m lan 機能ジャンパーっと
思っているんです
当然強いわけですから子供はですねちょっととどうしようって思うわけです
そんな時皆さん親子だったらどんなこういう賭けをするでしょうか
2わっっ
頑張ってとか
へ登ったら騎士綺麗だよとかってね励ますと思うんですね
このキャンプでそういうことするとめっちゃ怒られるんです
なんでかっていうと
の中の気持ちのダメージを受けていたリフトをこの子っていうのは
自分の主体性が傷ついちゃってるんです
分の判断や1よりも周りの人をとな友達がいうことの方が大事になっちゃってる
そういう子が大人に背中押されたら
登っちゃうんですでもそれは自分で思ったんじゃなくて登らされた体験なんです
景色が見れるかもしれないけどゆえに持って帰れるのは何もないんです
一方登れなかった子はどうなるかというと
泣きたいしてもらったのに僕登れなかったって思うんですがんばれがんばれって言って
もいいって言うから
ということはですね自尊心が傷つくんです
応援ありえ
覚えた登らされたら下地ちょっとされません登れなかったら
自尊心が下がっちゃう
じゃあどうするか僕ら応援しないんですよ
うまい言い方こんな言い方僕だったりします
あの絵 the 10m ぐらいあるかなぁ
登った景色きれいだろうねぇ
でも落ちたらまあ侵入しないけど骨折来するかもしれないなぁ
でも大丈夫下には保健の先生もゆ4救急車だって売れるからどうする
なんつってニヤニヤしながらね聞いてみた人がです
そうする前子供となるかっていうねどどうしを登りたいけどでも気がすんのやだし観て
ね葛藤が生まれるんですよね
その葛藤の中でも上るっていう決断をした行
これしたし up ですよ
リスクは勝っ食べてやるわけですから勇気を出したっていう経験ですよね
俺持って帰れます
じゃあ
もこれなかった行
どうなるんでしょうかね
いや守りって言った方いたし僕こんな風にいますそっかぁまぁ
危険をあえてやる必要ないしねそれも良い反応なんじゃないよさかーりさー降りてきた
子にさご褒美のおかしい私たいんだけどキミあっているよなんてお願いします
そうするとその後めっちゃ頑張り
見えをばん回みたいな感じね
そんなフォンに対してですね僕はこんなこういう仮定します
だとなぁ君てくれてほんとよかったわああ
おめるできたかできないかで揉めるいうことじゃなくってあなたがここにいてくれて
よかったっていう存在を認めるこういうわけなんです
ほいこーゆー回か押していきます
そうすると3個
あのまま検討に戻ってねそのより寝るときねもうやめをするんです
もう
どういうモヤモヤかというと
あの時頑張って登るって言っとけ良かった気も m なんです
てねあのすごい目キルでし良かったっていうふうにおかしい私てるわけですが悔しい
わけですよ
から次の日ね木と樹の間をねっカーッとか車で行く
でしたに川が流れてみたらもうちょっと怖いアクティビティに
僕やりますみたいな感じでこうガチガチになって言ってきたりとかするんですよ
そしたらその子は俺主体性めっちゃ up ですよね
そんなことを通しですね
物より思い出なんですねいますけどいや
思い出より自分で選んだ体験の方が大事なんじゃないかなというふうに思い
どういうことかというと
人生の中で自分で自分の
決断をしていいんだって言っ
そういう実感する体験なんです俺主体性
こういうのができるような状況僕らが用意するっていうのがすごく大事なんじゃないか
なと思いました
これ
今度は学校に来
これを応用しました u ターン作戦というのは僕は考えました
不登校の子がねあの車でお母さんに連れられて来前まで行くわけですよ
それで校門でもう行く行かないで引っ張り合うするなんてことがよく起こるんです
それってえっとまぁよくある光景なんですけど
よくないのは子供も辛いしもう終わって結局やがった元気なくなっちゃうし
皆さんだったらどんなアイディア
こんなことを考えました
お母さんね言うわけですよお母さん統制あの入ってもなかなか上手くないですよね
盲学校までもうまでいけたらもうまで来て ok ってことにして子供が
そこで折れなかったら一種でも躊躇したも u ターンしましょうと帰る気にアイスで
も買って帰ってくださいと
今まで来て良かったねってそれをお願いします
このことを子供とも商談して伝えて下さい
次の日お母さんところが学校によする打ってねっ
8肛門が近づいてくるよね子供だんだん方がこうやってくるとか頬に口徒歩
そうですね一番やなことに直面するわけですから
えっと校門の前で止まってお母さんのちらどこにのかミート本には
無いってかもしれん
失敗しまーすで出ようとすると子供が切手って急にドア穴アイパー無理なんですねある
翌朝はあ
辛いんだなと思ってて u ターンしますもう絶対いう探せっても約束しますからね
学校が遠ざかると子供の体からだんだん力差のきていきます
表情も柔らかくなって
ぽろりぽろりと普段言えなかったことを話せたします
お母さんはそこで
この本としたかったんだなって思うんです
母親って大概はあのどっかでこのコーナー負けてるんじゃないかなってどんな一緒に
思っちゃうんです
周りからもそうやってね言われるしだけどもうこの子は葛藤して苦しいっていうところ
家庭に付き添うことでその辛さを理解して認めることができるようになったんです
軽くにアイス食って帰ったらもうちょっと子ども元気になってるわけですね
あの楽になって言われても違う
そうすると子供の中に何が起こるかって言ったらまあ
さっきの木登りと同じです
あの時肛門に入ってたらもうちょっと行きだしてから今頃給食食ってるがマナー畜生
って思うわけですよ
これを後6回繰り返すと7回目ぐらいの時に
なんか朝起きてからもう
てきて下で待っていたりと思うんですね小座間台がないのみたいな感じ
であそれでこそ ap た感じ車のして肛門まで来ると普通取りでも虚サイっちゃう
そいつなった子ってその後でまた不当ことがならないですよ
何故かといえば心が成長したから
えっとほどものね心って言うのはね僕をチョコみたいなもんだと思うんです
動画ねあのちょっとあったらもう苦しくなっちゃうんです溢れちゃう
だから親とかは先回りしてこぼれないようにしようとしたり立ったり
選択するの尾根子供選択するワイン
いいよにましてしまおうとしちゃうんです
でもねこのお母さん頑張ったんですそういうことをしないでこの子は自分で決めれる
よう目
なるまで支えてたんです
ここにありますよね
お酒よねやってあふれるとこうなす受けてみようなこのお母様っすんだったんですよ
このまっすんならはねなかなか難しいんです
ネガティブ系パブリティっていう言葉があるんですけどこれ
iy な職に耐える力っていう風
いいんじゃないかと思います
人限定あのこれどうなるかなってわからないとき
例えばこのかあさんだったら今日この小学校に行かなかったら一生学校行かないんじゃ
ないかって
本当は絶対そんなことないでしょでもそんな風に気持ちになっちゃうんです
未来がわからないから
だかこの曖昧な状況を3台の不安に耐えれるっていう力がとても大事なんじゃないかな
人教えですね大事なんじゃないかなって思う
話変わりますけど
皆さん人に相談して
がっかりした体型ありますか
ありますよね
それはきっと話す途中で帰られちゃったりとか
ちょっとそれ違うなっていうアドバイスをもらったり立ったりとか
なんかその92いやそりゃあんたちょっとそれあんたがおかしいんじゃないみたいね
批判されちゃったりとか
そうするとなんだあの相談し損だったなってなるんじゃないでしょうかね
それどういうことかというとですね
こういう感じです
どう相手の
つわりも自分の妻が大きくないと相手の気持ちをしたで受け止めることができないん
です
おちょこの上にますが持ってたらひっくり返っちゃいますよね
こういうことが起こっちゃう
だーらー
を心って嘘
いくんでしょうか
実は僕にはですね心の大きな器の
しょうがいます訴訟今から紹介します
21分アメリカンのべんじ衣装ですこの人
1回んです体もすっごいでっかいんですけど心はまあ子供をチョコだとしたらこの人は
ビア樽ぐらいの大きさがあるんですよね
どんどんど僕初めて会ったのがですねまぁあの
草原の中の空港ネバーわーっとアメリカで降りてってデーっとまぁそこから降りると
で僕が65外出たらその後の便子さんとあのまあ奥さんがいて便子さんの車は
ピックアップトップフロント sp っとこうなんかはれてるんですよねうん子さん
グラスかけてこうやって立っている
雑魚やと思ってあの一緒に行ったんがまあ奥さんのクルマに乗っちゃって僕ひとりで
ピックアップとこの助成金を張ってちょこんと座るわけですね
車発信するんですけども何しゃべっていいかわかんないとって初の海外旅行だし英語が
しゃべったことないし
をどうしようと思ってまあそう走ってたら向こうにね黒いお子がいたんですよね
道端にやっぱアメリカですね
チャンスだと思ったんです
エンジン言ってみたんです
スペア
早くまで使って
ソーシャル返事こっちこうやって冬未定
終わって思って
もうちょっと言って今度は黒い犬がいたんですよね
もうもう1回切りましたさ
ベアドゥ
ベジこっち見て
俺もらったなと思いますねこれ大丈夫だとすごい安心しました
すごい便子と仲良くなっていろんなことをね相談しました
僕は相談に来て英語喋りなり何そだしたんだと思うんですけど僕はベンチそうだがある
のだよって言うとがちょっとここ座るようなんっつって言ってベンチはこうやって座っ
て
おやすみな感じで方
もう es でしか答えで微動だにせずいっかーっと受け止めてくれるんですね
これなんだと
プロのカウンセラーで日本こんな人ランナーと思ってベンチに聞いてみたんです
そしたら
おじいちゃんが聞いてくれるのと同じように聞いてるだけだよって言うんですね
インディアンすげーなと思ったんです
そんなんや心の首相に僕学んだことがあります心坊さんを拾い方で各する方法
これべんじはいろんなネガティブなことたとえば自分が約束すっぽかされても何か失敗
してもねあの前 vs て肯定してくれるんです
肯定する力がすごいんです
北日本語にするとそれもあり力だと思うんですよね
腰すごい大事なことなんで皆さんと一緒にちょっと練習してみたいと思います
僕が性能って言った目3それもアリって言ってくれますか
いいですか
いきますよせーの
もういただきますせーの
ありがとうございます
なんか気持ちでモヤモヤしちゃってなんか神代記自分で切ったら切りすぎて変な頭に
なっちゃったーーーー
せーのっ
ありがとうございます友達にハムいるって言われているッ
行ったら実はハムスターでしかもそれがつがいで12匹まで増えちゃってもとをして
いいかわかんない生の
ありがとうございます
レンタルビデオ回数忘れて延滞料金10,000円
ええの
ありがとうございますもすごい僕あの受け止めてもらえた肯定された気がします
それもありこれだけ覚えてもらってね帰ってもいいぐらいですこれ癖みたいねだったり
と思います
はい
皆さん
いろいろ話してきましたけど
この成長の秘密
ハッピーと期待でしょうか
心の成長の秘密
肯定する力ゾーンです
のことでいいんですよ例えばあの自分が今やったことない新しいことに挑戦するかどう
かって迷うとき
カット生まれますよね
例えば嫌いな人にあのどうしても話さなきゃいけないとちょっと打ってある
といえばそうですねあの
自分があの
西いくらやっても
解決できないことにいつまでも挑み続けなきゃいけない
いろんなこんながあります好きな子にフラれちゃうこともあったりするかもしれないし
それこといくらでもありますよね
baby g が言ってたのは
辛いことをこんなことの裏側にある
焦点を当てる例えばすっぽかされてもすっぽかされたおかげで違う人と会えたりところ
する事ってありますよね電車乗り遅れてえっとそこで誰かに親切にすることができたり
立ったり
そんな肯定的な女にどんどんどんどん光を当てていくっていうのはね
たちなんじゃないかたという
えっとまぁ
人間生きているとですね色んな辛いことありますよね
で
そうそう接するこんなに合う事ってあると思うんですそれ僕であっても皆さんであって
も
そんな時ってあのついつい自分のことでもれ
アランでおらんなことしたバカだって思ったりとか誰かがそう言ってこんなツラもした
んだっていうのはね話を聞いてもね
あんた何とそのおっしゃったのみたいなことを言ったりついつい否定しちゃうんです
それもうこんなんが大きすぎてびっくりしちゃって本当はその人を励ましたり温めたい
のに
も言えない
どうやっていったらいいんでしょうか
僕はこういうふうに
そんな大変な思いしてでも良く今生きてここにいてくれるねってそんなふうに伝えます
つまりその人が今目の前に存在していることを肯定していくんです
自分のことでも同じ例えば荒北がすごいまあまあ良くする頭が大きな失敗しもうこんな
んだけどおいしいんだほうがええんちゃうかな
でもそんな申し出を得んちゃうかなって思いながらここにいろれ
まあ
結構いいから生の
ありがとうございますまずそこでそれまで航程敷けば一番いいんですよね
えっとほんとはねでもそうやって皆さんカマっすになって自分の身近な人本当に苦しい
時にその人を肯定しながら一生にこんなお声で受けることができたらあなたの器も
広がります
そしてえっ助けた人と自分の間に肯定的なつながりができるんです
牧草やつながりはどんどん社会に広がっていくといい社会になっていくって確信するん
です僕の身の回りからでいいんです
最後にここで皆さん今日僕とそれもありでつながれたと思うんです
だ皆さん
今日今この瞬間から新しいことちょっとこんなんだなと思うほど嫌いな人と話しかけ
たりとか話したりすることなんでもいいです
自分のこんなんだこれダメだって持っていることに皇帝の光を与えていこうじゃない
ですか
そんな風に皆さんとそれ周りを共有したいと思っています
せーの
ああああああ
ありがとうござました
[拍手]